I do a coffee at a daily seven days per week for about a year, though, is it possible to
develop a sensitivity to caffeine? So the answer to that is yes, you can. By fitness
band recently noted high heart rate in the evening after doing a coffee at a
well, you will, if you absorb some caffeine, which you typically will, when you do a
coffee out of it, it will raise your heart rate. 150 plus beats per minute. And that to
be is too high. I also reduced my thyroid bed. I like to see your thyroid labs if you
have them. Should I stop animals or continue with less coffee? I would just switch to
to do it. And it was with the cannibal tea to just make up, grew up some organic cannibal
tea. And to switch to that for a week or two and see if that changes on your fitness
band. So this fitness band, I think you're talking about is those things that you wear and you
can measure your heart rate and stuff like that. I know some of you looked at fitness band
remember that 80s punk band, but no, that's not what he's talking about. So yeah, I would
change it. I would go less coffee. I would just change it to a cannibal tea, edema, and that's
what I would do. Don't sit for panic here with prostate cancer. Don't sit for panic here
with prostate cancer. I would do one pack. So if you're getting the panic here in the boxes
and there's three packs, one gram each each packet. Do one pack a day. Start with four days on
three days off. Four days on three days off. You could put it in your smoothie. You could mix
it straight, but it's better to throw it in your smoothie or your greens or something like that.
And it's fairly tasteless. Do four days on three days off. That's what I would do for prostate cancer.